STEPHANIE WONG:
On the outside, it
might seem that people in
pageants just strut on stage
and wear really nice outfits.
That is true, but
on top of that,
the pageant world today is made
up of extremely strong women
across all industries who are
doing some incredible work,
whether it's entrepreneurship or
fighting for a nonprofit cause.
I'm Stephanie Wong,
and this is my journey
to becoming a
developer advocate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I got interested in beauty
pageants a little unexpectedly.
I grew up in San Francisco,
where Miss Chinatown
USA has been a big part of the
Chinese culture for over 60
years.
So I always looked
up to the idea
of maybe trying it one day.
But it wasn't until
after college,
when I'd worked for
a couple of years
and had established
myself in my career a bit
and was able to take
a couple weeks off,
that I decided to
make my first attempt.
And when I got in, I
had zero expectations
of winning whatsoever.
SPEAKER: Contestant number
four, Stephanie Wong
from Millbrae, California.
STEPHANIE WONG: For
one of my pageants,
I did aerial silks acrobatics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I also tried things like
Brazilian samba, Chinese dance,
and hip hop.
So to my surprise,
I won the pageant.
The biggest thing I learned
from doing beauty pageants
for the first time was
realizing how rewarding
it is to try things and get
out of your comfort zone.
I performed a brand-new
talent that I never done
before, aerial silks, in
front of a new community
that I had never been
in front of, either.
But it ended up being such
a life-changing experience
for me.
One, I was extremely proud
of being an Asian-American.
I was able to be an ambassador.
But I was also able to meet
lifelong friends who are also
professionally experienced
and really successful
in all industries.
So pageant experience has gotten
me to propel me in my career
by making me a great
speaker, standing up
for a cause I truly
believe in, and building
a community from the ground up.
The community that I've
built have helped me
in my video creation
work in technology
because I'm able to leverage
a network, learn from them,
conduct workshops
alongside them,
and practice my communication
skills at a wide level.
I absolutely love video creation
because of so many things
that I think have become
apparent in my life--
my love for performing,
my love for working
with a team of really
talented people,
and having creative influence
from beginning to end.
And I think that's something
that has been strung along
in my dance experience, along
with my pageant experience
and a lot of the things
that I do outside of work.
I am so inspired by
this work because I
am able to tap into
a community online
of learners and people who
come from varied backgrounds,
just like myself.
If there's one thing that
I want people to take away
from my career, it's that
staying authentic will
allow you to have a much
more fulfilling life,
and using your interests outside
of work to infuse your career
is going to enrich
your life overall.
Having this rich life
outside of just my career
is so important to
making me the person
I am at the job every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]